my name is chad sanderson
i work for a company called convoy which
i'm going to talk about
in just a little bit
so like sean was saying i have a pretty
diverse set of experiences building
experimentation platforms and programs
across
late stage startups big legacy companies
like microsoft and very old companies
that haven't even migrated to the cloud
like subway
so i hope that this talk will be really
interesting for you
because it's going to be my perspective
on the philosophy and framework around
standing up these types of programs
regardless of what sort of company
you're working for
but for now we're going to focus mainly
on
convoy and how we think about
experimentation at scale and bring in
some of those other experiences a little
bit
later a little bit about convoy first
convoy is a two-sided b2b freight
marketplace driven by machine learning
on one side of our marketplace we have
shippers
and those shippers are trying to
transport freight from facility to
facility and on the other side we have a
carrier and carriers own fleets of
trucks that are taking that freight
convoy sits in the middle and optimizes
it with machine learning okay
now the ceo of convoy is dan lewis
and dan is coming from amazon and as i'm
sure you guys know amazon has a really
awesome experimentation culture and he
brings that with him to convoy
so
my job and our job as a data platform
team is to enable
every product team at convoy to do
experimentation as self-service rapidway
and because of that we did a huge
evaluation of experimentation products
back in about 2018 before we decided
which way to go forward
and the tldr of the entire presentation
really at least for me
is that the existing experimentation
platform technology
currently serves a very specific
customer and a very specific use case
and that use case is
super high traffic websites
tons of samples
that focuses on click stream events so
that's things happening in your front
end your applications websites mobile
apps things like that so if you fall
outside of this use case
the current stack doesn't really help
you that much
so what i would advise one of your main
takeaways of this talk should be
is that instead of asking the question
how do we run a b tests what's the
platform that we need in order in order
to run a b test really quickly you
should start asking the question
how do we measure important things
and what are those important
things so i want to talk about the
framework that i used when setting up
the experimentation product and program
at convoy and how that trickled over
into the some of the other places that i
worked at
so
the first place to start
is use cases
what are the measurement use cases in
the experimentation use cases that are
very very important to your business
specifically
the first thing we need to think about
within use cases is what makes convoy
unique as a company
and like i already mentioned we are an
mo based b2b marketplace startup and
there's a few important things
to think about
there the first one is that we have a
lot of models we have a pricing model we
have an eta model we have a relevance
model
and those models are iterated over very
very quickly so whatever our solution is
needs to be able to handle a very high
volume of iteration
on machine learning models that's number
one number two is where a b2b frame
where a b2b marketplace
and when you have a two-sided
marketplace
it means that just randomizing on your
typical entities like randomizing on
customers is going to cause bias on the
other side of the marketplace
so you need to be able to randomize on
entities that are outside of that
traditional cdp framework so for us that
would be
geographies regions time stuff like that
and then finally we have very very small
volume
and oftentimes not only we're trying to
optimize the customer experience we're
also trying to optimize our operational
efficiency
so we have a small amount of customers
shippers that are really really
important to us like walmart they're
trying to move some freight and we need
to make sure that they don't get really
angry at us and don't want to ship
freight anymore so we need to make sure
that our ops team which is a
non-automated part of our business is
super efficient
so all those use cases i just listed are
on the left over there under the convoy
column
but those use cases are really really
different from what i experienced at
microsoft and at subway
so at microsoft we didn't just have one
product we had a ton of products and
many of those products were sort of
stitched together in weird ways
so
bing office teams
are huge right these are millions of
customers
sometimes hundreds of millions of
customers or entities
truly enormous sample sizes that means
if you know anything about
experimentation you're going to get very
very small results very quickly we don't
have that issue at convoy
some of our products are ml centric bing
right it's ranking algorithm so you're
running experiments on that all the time
but xbox is a lot more focused on the
product experience
and in microsoft store
you're really focused on marketing right
conversion funnels
and then finally a big difference was
that safety was a really core priority
right when you have hundreds of millions
of customers
and many of those customers are
leveraging microsoft products and
critical workflows they can't fail if
they fail it's a huge huge problem it's
a big deal it's a problem that we don't
have at convoy right now
so ensuring that things are safe and not
breaking was equally as important as
like this new feature is making money
at subway similar issue a little
different
we had a website and we had a mobile app
very small sample sizes
massive sample sizes in the store huge
foot traffic in fact subway is actually
the largest franchise by volume uh quick
service restaurant in the united states
a little fact for you zero machine
learning none at all everything is going
through either the marketing website or
what's happening in the store
and so the main focus there is figuring
out how do we message our new sandwiches
and wraps effectively
very very different use cases to think
about
next is metrics so we've got our use
cases but what are the things that we
actually need to measure in order to
show demonstrate value in roi from our
experiments
convoy is a startup that means we have
to prove to our shareholders we're
growing very quickly we also have to
prove that we're margin positive right
we're not building products that like
fundamentally don't scale so growth
based metrics are super important
financial metrics are super important
and those financial and growth metrics
have to be very very accurate they can't
be super wrong
and that means we need to go to the
source of truth which is the data
warehouse
so when we are creating metrics we need
to be able to write queries against the
data warehouse
for example margin variable cost per
shipment and the price of shipments
relative to the market we don't want to
be over bidding or under bidding on on
shipments
the same issue here
we have all these experience metrics
around growth you know number of bid
intents
was the pickup on time or not
you know how many how many minutes did a
carrier actually spend taking a
particular piece of freight we have all
the financial metrics i mentioned and
then we also have the operational
efficiency metrics that i mentioned
before so how many inbound emails are we
getting are we able to reduce that
how many quotes are we getting how many
of those uh those those shipper issues
are turning into escalations
microsoft very very different right
being focused primarily on
advertising
right ad results um
how many people are clicking on these
ads what are we showing what's the
relevancy of them
office was focused on the product
how many documents are being created
saved edited and so on
and on the store it's more like
conversion rate optimization so are we
getting people through that pipeline
very quickly
for subway
we also focused it focused a lot on the
marketing side so that conversion
optimization funnel
but we weren't primarily interested in
getting people to buy a lot of things
what we wanted to do was take our
customers that were in the store and
convert them to loyalty members and
upsell them that was the main focus of
the experimentation some of the
experimentation on the website
but we also cared about metrics in the
store itself with the number one being
mix so subway releases a whole bunch of
new sandwiches and wraps and drinks and
combos and things like that and what
they want to measure is when they do
that are those new items then
represented in whatever the mixes of
that store by region so we have to be
able to to measure that very accurately
and then finally we come to
the organizational setup for
experimentation
in convoy's case like i already
mentioned this is part of the dna of the
company so your promotions are based on
experiment results whether or not a
feature is shipped is based on
experiment results
and because of that
we needed to give everybody the power to
serve experiments very very quickly and
the data had to be right right if your
promotion is based on an experiment the
data can't be wrong that's going to be a
huge a huge issue
so our focus was on self-service and
accuracy
but again at microsoft big difference
many different companies different
stages of maturity some of them knew
what experimentation was and prioritized
it really highly some of them didn't do
any experimentation at all
so that means that we needed to have a
centralized team and that centralized
team acted as a locus of customer
success we were enablers so sometimes
we're actually building the pipelines
for teams sometimes we're just advising
on experiments sometimes we're even
coming up with experiment designs
at subway we had no data scientists
nobody knew what experimentation was
i was introducing it to the company for
the very first time
and so our team our experimentation
program group we did everything we
designed the experiment we built it we
developed it we deployed it and we
analyzed it
okay
so from convoy's perspective
an ideal technical stack has these
attributes
assignment metrics and analysis
assignment is how do we randomize the
entities that we really care about
we needed feature flag abilities we
needed to gradually deploy these types
of changes
we needed to filter entities down to
specific personas we cared about
and we needed to trigger experiments on
certain events
on the metric side
we needed the ability to compute metrics
in the data warehouse in sql
that was a huge requirement and use case
and we also needed to be able to
discover those metrics really cleanly
and efficiently and have that metric
repository act as a source of truth
and on the analysis side we had a whole
bunch of statistical use cases we needed
to facilitate and that meant supplying a
range of algorithms and visualizations
and segmentation capabilities
so what that practically looked like was
something like this these are all the
applications in each area on the
assignment side we had more customer-ish
entities like carriers and shippers but
we also had trucks rfps and shipments
on the metric side we had click events
but we also had financial events
operational cost shipment duration
service failures
and on the analysis side yes we did
basic things like t-tests but we also
did pretty advanced things like causal
impact and downstream impact
the modern or the current
experimentation tools though when we did
our evaluation of what existed really
only provided us this
right so we got
we were able to randomize on customers
carriers and shippers using our front
end applications
the metrics that we recorded were from
click stream events
and the analysis that we could do was
limited to t-tests
this is obviously like a big problem
right this is like 75 plus of our
experimentation use cases are not
supported so how much value does a b
testing really have
so the core problem here is that what we
observed
even after this audit was only
the the tip of the iceberg for
experimentation convoy is going to grow
there's going to be more product
surfaces there's things that we didn't
even cover i didn't talk to the sales
team very much for example so what we
really needed was a flexible platform
that allows us to randomize on any any
entity compute any metric
and perform any type of analysis that we
wanted
and like most engineering teams will
tell you what that typically results in
if you have a huge
gap in what you need versus what exists
is you just build it yourself
so
we built it ourselves it took us four
engineers
and multiple years of effort and that
effort is still ongoing but the good
news is we solve the problem
right and we're actually enabling
experimentation across every single
corner of convoy today so the big use
case here that i want to leave you with
is make sure you're structuring your
experimentation system around the
business use cases and the needs
and not a generic application of a b
testing don't just follow the crowd and
if you select the wrong tool at the
wrong stage of your customer's life
cycle or your business life cycle
then you could be limiting the value of
experimentation for years to come
and with that i'm going to pass it over
to someone who is working on solving a
lot of these problems that convoy
focused on but spend engineering time
that's jay with apple i got that mic
here oh he's got the bike cool
all right thanks chad so
as chad mentioned i'm ceo here of epo
and what we're trying to do is take the
same concepts that he was talking about
measure what matters and measure it kind
of in a democratized fashion and making
that available to people who are not
going to have the experimentation teams
of convoy
so i'll start off with a quick
background about myself i'm not going to
read all these things but i think the
main call-outs i was pretty early airbnb
i saw a lot of that journey both from a
data technology standpoint as well as a
data culture standpoint but crucially i
also went to a bunch of other places and
saw kind of difference in metrics the
difference in organization the
difference in goals most recently that
was at webflow where i was the second
data scientist but before that i also
had my logistics stint in next trucking
and so i got to experience that a little
bit
um
my
head of data engine comes from
snowflakes so he brings a lot of the
kind of database type of backgrounds but
the
a big thing to realize is that when we
built experimentation at airbnb this was
a different era we had to do it with a
bunch of open source distributed compute
platforms like hive and pig and stuff
like that nowadays no one has to do this
anymore we have this modern data stack
that i'm pretty i bet most people in the
room are now using which is we have some
combination of snowflake redshift
bigquery and then a transformation layer
top like dbt or airflow and then there's
now an increasing constellation of tools
around that and so with that you can
start doing things like experimentation
really early on so most recently i was
at webflow that was a series a company
and we were running all these
experiments
and with that in the reason why so many
people
run experiments it's pretty obvious for
anyone who's been part of these programs
is
experimentation starts to open your eyes
to this basic fact
that you're shipping all these things
and you think they're all fantastic but
it turns out around the third of them
are actually good and this is a success
rate that's been corroborated in a whole
bunch of environments so at microsoft
bing google airbnb netflix there have
been papers published about it that
basically of the things you launch only
a third of them are actually very
effective and so if that's the case then
you really need to know what third is
happening at a given moment in time
so the companies that realize this do
the convoy thing where we build this big
in-house system you know throw engineers
an internal tool the airbnb one we built
is on top here but you know many of the
other unicorns have their own
and under the hood they all have this
architecture this is basically the
architecture of every single
experimentation system in existence
and in this talk you i'm actually going
to go deep on each one of these
components and the thing i want to
really make a takeaway
is that experimentation is really like
under the hood in terms of
infrastructure it's around a bunch of
different components
that are each have a bit of depth in to
their complexity and they all have to
work in concert to get the roa roi you
want so this talk is going to be about
going through every single one of these
components talking about their failure
modes and opportunities for
impact to make your program more
successful
starting with the randomization side now
the randomization side is typically what
most people think of as what
experimentation is and so there's
actually a decent amount of commercial
tooling that around how to do it
under the hood all commercial tooling
looks like this so whether it's a launch
darkly or kind of most in-house tools
they all have a way to
convey experiment configurations saying
like here are all the experiments going
on right now here's how the allocations
of 50 50
40 60 whatever sort of thing
and these experimentation configs are
being synced onto clients let's say
every 15 minutes or so
so it and they need to be served fairly
quickly i think the modern principles to
use cdns around them and kind of in the
background kind of consume the configs
and what that does is with these
experiment metadata stored locally
now you can it's a very quick low
latency process to then split users into
different groups and typically you have
some sort of function let's call it get
variation get treatment group whatever
it is that you can call and that's the
mean devrel experience of most engineers
is that you know they don't have to
worry too much that there's this
underlying sdk that's syncing things
they just say hey
you know here's the experiment going on
put me in the group and that function
also crucially is going to uh spit an
event back to your warehouse and say
this person is in this experiment
so
you know there's kind of iterations on
the underlying technology but this is
the basic uh framework of it
and another big thing is when you do
this randomization the kind of
best-in-class way to do it is md5 hashes
that has a nice property where you can
do it offline you can do it online you
can replicate how it's going to be
randomized and it's just always going to
do the same thing it's item pun so you
know past if this user hits the same
experiment 10 times they're going to end
up with the same treatment group
so this is the randomization side and
you know i've been in many companies
where they started off by randomizing
like the last digit of a user id or
something like that there are other ways
to try to get started but
what's tricky is some methods like if
you call a rand function are not
idempotent you can't just get the same
thing every time and some methods like
last digits might not be as random as
they think um and especially if you did
what we did at webflow originally where
zero through four are always treatment
and five through nine are always control
and so you have a long-term set of
guinea pigs so this is kind of where
most companies end up
then we have metric side and
this is somewhere this is an area of
passion for me because i think this is
something where a lot of experimentation
programs mess up and i think the biggest
thing
takeaway that chad touched on already is
experimentation programs get a lot more
powerful if you use business metrics so
i see so many companies they start off
running experiments and they just use
the metrics that are kind of available
with the existing tooling which tends to
be like click conversions you know like
someone signed up something like that
and yes you can boost those metrics but
it's not really gonna get many people's
attention that you boosted signups like
you really want to show that you boosted
revenue or bookings or purchases
um the kind of quick sentence i always
say is like if you show this experiment
result to your cfo would they care
and that's actually going to be a big
deal because it determines like you know
who gets resourcing you know how this
all falls out so
to get the real value of experimentation
you want to use stripe data or you know
data from all the different points of
sale so
in the end it basically means you need
to connect to the warehouse
the other thing i want to mention is
because people are so used to taking
these shallow click metrics they usually
look at uh steps kind of higher up in
the funnel so again i mentioned sign ups
or like filling out a form or something
like that but i just want to let people
know about a certain pattern that we saw
over and over airbnb and at webflow
which is that
the vast majority of experiments will
boost one part of the funnel and then
depress the other and they'll end up
right neutral and this is we saw this
over and over in the search funnel just
back in the day airbnb you had to first
request a book before you got accepted
and so you'd search you'd contact a
person then they would accept and then
you could do a booking
and
almost every experiment would inflict
one part and make everyone go down so
this is another reason to use business
metrics because then you can at least
have confidence that you're not just
like
kind of playing whack-a-mole with funnel
now we have the sufficient stats part
and this is
it's called sufficient statistic
statistics because that's what you're
actually calculating to fuel your
analytics results but it's really a big
data engineering problem
so this is the dag that most uh
pipelines end up working with for
experimentation so on one end you have
those assignment events that i've talked
about from the randomization system on
the other hand you have these metrics
these fact concepts such as a purchase
such as you got revenue and then you got
to join them together
to say of these different purchases how
many ended up how many were part of this
experiment
and then from there you kind of group it
first to an experiment subject level and
then an experiment level the thing i
really want to emphasize is that this
dag
it's really all the action is really in
that first join it's basically a big
join and then two group eyes and the
group buys happen pretty quickly you
know most engine data engineering teams
don't lose a lot of stress or compute
around two group eyes but i join you
know it's so large that if you look at
airbnb uh in this experimentation
program somewhere around like a third of
all compute cost is happening with this
experiment join it's like a very big
deal so it's
uh most of the optimizations end up
around there
then we get to the statistics tests and
this is the part that uh it gets a lot
of play in the discourse you know the
academics get to get involved also
because they do these sort of things and
there's kind of like holy wars between
frequentists and vasanism and stuff like
that
the thing i want to mention around stat
test is that
most people most programs i would say
like 95 of experimentation programs
basically just write a t-test
and
while this isn't necessarily wrong
it puts a lot of onus of expertise on
your organization because there's a
bunch of failure modes for t-tests
specifically if you run a t-test
you're not supposed to look at the
results until it's done so you make this
promise saying that like we're gonna
start out this experiment we're gonna
run it until we have a thousand samples
in both groups and then we're gonna look
at the results and make a decision
now anyone who's ever run an
experimentation program knows everyone
looks at this every day like no one's
actually gonna not look at the thing for
weeks and so that already is just
inviting misuse when you use these
t-test methods
and then there are a bunch of other
failures to deal with outliers and the
types of metrics you're using
specifically once you do ratio metrics
you can no longer use the t-test you
have to use a thing called the delta
method
there's a bunch of things that people
don't fully realize and in the process
they just suddenly incur a lot of false
positives so
the the thing with
to implement pushes a lot of expertise
and required hand-holding onto your
experts
in comparison i'm going to tell you
about a few other things that might help
so one is there's a method called
sequential testing so this is what
optimizely uses it's getting a lot more
play recently and what it mainly touches
on is that the uh
the t-test thing
operates with this kind of static
decision boundary the saying like if the
you know if the p-value is below 0.05
it's going to trigger but the vast
majority of experiments kind of look
like this where they will intermittently
be significant and then revert regress
back to normal whereas the sequential
analysis what it does is it has a more
dynamic boundary and it says that like
early on
if it's a really large effect size sure
you can have a significant result but
over time it's going to narrow into
something that converges more and this
has a nice property because it just
builds in the idea that you're going to
look at every day like it just embraces
that these organizations are going to
potentially call the experiment on any
given moment time
and so boom you've already removed the
whole like you know hold people's hand
make sure they don't look at the results
early thing
other ways that can really help by your
organization there's a whole class of
problems called variance reduction of
which the most well-known is cupid and
i always bring this up because people
don't realize that with advanced
statistical methods there's actually
free money out there to make your
organization run faster specifically you
can take these experiments that take
something like two months and they can
actually run in let's say a month and a
half you can kind of save two weeks of
product time increase your learning rate
uh it delivers a lot of value and it's
it's one of those rare kind of free
lunch sort of situations where like if
you have to know how to implement it you
actually just
win
um the way i explain it is i have this
one analogy around suppose you're
mcdonald's and suppose you're running an
experiment to boost uh the sales of
happy meals
um what the the easy way to do it is to
run some experiment and then see
did the number of happy meals go up
but there's actually this interesting
insight you can say is that suppose
every time someone walks in the door
you're gonna make a guess on if they're
gonna buy a hat meal and then you're
just gonna compare how they did against
your guesses
now if you did that paradigm you would
say stuff like well
if someone walks in with three kids i
think they're gonna get a hat meal
like where is the kind of person
stumbling in with a hangover you know
like 40 year old whatever is probably
not going to get a happy meal or even
more obviously if someone previously
purchased happy meals they're probably
going to purchase a happy meal and so
what this means is that suddenly you are
taking accounts for some natural
variation
and just kind of removing it from the
equation getting a lot more signal
so in practice it's really just a linear
regression it's not actually anything
super fancy but it does mean you have to
get kind of metric calculations before
the experiment get the history of the of
the person
so if you look at a place like an airbnb
or a microsoft or a facebook or whatever
they've all implemented this thing it's
become a mainstream method it's just
because it involves some more complexity
both on a data engineering standpoint
and a statistics standpoint you don't
see it in the commercial landscape
then we get to the the issue of
diagnostics and this is actually one of
those experimentation and scale things
where
there's just a lot of failure modes that
happen in experimentation and that you
have to make people aware of and make
people correct for it
and the best way to understand this is
uh
i don't know who all knows ron and
kojavi but he was a major influential
person in terms of
taking experimentation to the mainstream
and especially emphasizing the platform
version of it like the whole
organization's going to use this
platform the first word on this book is
trustworthy and experimentation is
really a big leap of faith of saying
like we're going to let this system
adjudicate who's who wins and who loses
so
trust is like the big underlying
principle of all of experimentation
so in terms of diagnostics the most the
final way the most common failure mode
is imbalanced treatment groups and this
is where you think it's a 50 50 split
it's actually let's say 5248 or
something like that like and
the problem is that that difference is
almost always a canary in coal mine that
there's actually an underlying issue
because the type of people who are
getting imbalance that are throwing off
this 50 50 split they're probably people
with low latency you know maybe they're
in a low connectivity area on their
phone or something or they're on a
client that is generally completely
broke but it's just the low percentage
of your traffic so you know me there
weren't that many android users for a
while and so maybe it was just really
broken in android
and so the way to check for this there's
a thing called the sample ratio mismatch
test you know
most people would run it as a straight
chi-square test but there's another
sequential version that you can run
every day
in my experience every time there's an
imbalance it's always an actual problem
it's never something you can kind of
quickly rush away so if you look at
mainstream experimentation tools they
all build in this check as part of
day-to-day practice
so that's diagnostic number one
imbalanced treatment groups
number two is outliers
this is one of those sneaky truths for
in the world of data science that i wish
we'd all talk about much more
commonly
who here are sort of naseem celeb in the
black swan
so
the
you know this theme club kind of fiery
figure has a lot of opinions that you
know you can get in twitter wars with
but the fundamental principle he talks
about is that social phenomena
metrics follow power laws they do not
follow these kind of finite moment
distributions that basically all of
modern statistics are built off of
and
people with companies you all know this
you all have some level of outliers that
are just completely skewing things so
airbnb we have these hosts that we
called whale hosts now by and large
airbnb most hosts are just your typical
you know mom and pop with the extra room
sort of thing
uh but there are some hosts who are not
aren't just people they are corporations
that run a large portfolio of airbnb
homes
and
these people drive so many bookings that
if you were to just randomly divide
people into two groups
they would actually drive all the
results because there would be slight
differences in their allocations between
the two groups
and then the same thing happened at
webflow webflow is a no code website
building platform and there were some
people who were not just your freelancer
type who's building websites or people
they were a full agency they exist in
many countries they were building tons
and tons of websites and if you just
naively split them into two groups
they're again going to drive all the
outcomes
so
outliers it's a tough thing because
these power laws generally break modern
statistics there's a few ways of dealing
with them
the kind of classic way you that i would
that in academia you do it are
non-parametric tests so basically say
like we're not going to have
any assumptions around distributions
we're just going to use ranks and stuff
like that in practice these are the two
things i see
one is windsorization which basically
says take the 99th percentile and just
take that as the maximum
amount of this metric
the other is that method cupid i
mentioned because it accounts for prior
history it can actually
take out some of the outlier-ness of
outlier
and then this last one i'll touch on it
really quickly but one of the things
about experimentation is it makes your
underlying data quality issues invisible
so typically if you
have some sort of like your data is not
updating or there's some day that's
missing data you look at a line chart of
it and it's just broken right and it's
just obviously this is bad when you look
at experiment results it's equally
broken on both sides and so it kind of
just looks like an experiment result and
so making it really easy to know if data
quality is bad is you know a big deal
so then in terms of investigations i'm
going to go a little bit quickly here
because we're kind of nearing the end
but
i think one of the things every
experimentation practice learns is that
getting to a place where you're
delivering wins is a learning process
first you have to be able to run an
experiment at all and i've been part of
teams that have an okr that's literally
like run an experiment like at all
it's just getting all these pieces to
work together is tough but then when you
run these experiments you quickly
realize that you have all these bugs you
know you built this thing but you didn't
consider this one use case or you didn't
consider android properly or whatever
and so you have to learn to diagnose
quickly
and then you can actually get to a point
where you reliably deliver wins and the
most important way here to discover
these issues to learn is to be able to
segment results so at me or back in the
day uh this was a really common
situation you'd run this experiment it
looks good it looks like an overall
negative ish problem but once you split
it by something like browser it turns
out it just has a big ie bug and like it
was actually a good one but it was just
failing for that reason
so this can also happen the web flow
with different user personas the big
takeaway is to say you need to take your
results and be able to split them by
user segmentations make it readily
available make it democratized this is a
big part of being able to understand
experiments
and then at the end we get to this
reporting side
and i really feel like reporting is the
most uh like underrated part of data
science because you do all this work all
this complexity and in the end you're
supposed to drive a decision in the org
and that last mile of of data science is
really communication
as a give you a sense of what i mean i
just googled experiment templates and
jupiter and looker and stuff like that
and this is what i found
like it's big pile of numbers a bunch of
charts that you don't really understand
and this is having done a lot of
customer research this is the state of
the art of most companies
experimentation programs so basically
what you end up doing is building in the
concept that data science has data
scientists has to translate it to you
like a rosetta stone or something like
that it's like this big translation
process
so i think most programs it would
behoove them to think
what is a form of reporting that doesn't
assume so much context and knowledge it
doesn't assume you know what a p-value
is it doesn't assume you know what these
warehouse tables are or what these
metrics are or what is the right way to
look at revenue just really try to
simplify things so that if you just
threw like a junior pm straight out of
college in here it would actually be
able to make a decision so
that's the another piece of getting
experimentation to scale that i think is
just hugely underrated
all this is part of a general flywheel
you're trying to get going where
you know you start off you get one team
to try out this new workflow try running
an experiment expose yourself to
metrics as the main decider of winning
and then once you kind of go through
that you build up the infra you build up
the know-how you build up those muscles
and this eventually hopefully turns into
something
like an airbnb sized experimentation
program but all of it really comes down
to getting all these pieces to work
right in a way that matches your
business like chad is saying and can be
wielded by many people in the org
so yeah i'll stop there thank you all
for coming to our talk um my name is che
here's my email and twitter account i'd
love to hear what you think love to talk
about experimentation anytime i
especially love hearing kind of how it
plays out in different environments
different business models different
maturity stages
so yeah with that we'll wrap